when you see thousands of people that
are innocents that got killed by drones
a million innocents killed in Iraq if
that's not a crime against humanity what
is it crime against a lot of comes
up that people would want to vote on
like the bailouts the war or other thing
things of this nature there's a lot of
things that people would like it's gonna
affect us we would like to vote on this
but you don't get to vote on you get to
vote on a representative
these people gonna represent you once
they get into office and think about
some of the laws that are in place that
protect corporations think about some of
the laws that are in place that
people over every day they wouldn't be
there people were voting for them we all
have this this desire to have someone
lead us we all have this this feeling
where we need someone who's smarter and
wiser who represents us you know and
when you're really dumb the
problem is really dumb people they get a
say in everything - and there's it
they're subject to a lot of tricks
they're subjects to the they're subject
to nationalism they're subject to these
kind of ridiculous rah rah rah America
speeches that don't say jack they
say nothing it's all just this
cheerleading event and then
they're subjective they can't help it
they're dumb they don't know they're
being bullshitter D they grew up around
dumb people they go to work with dumb
people there's no one in their family
that's interesting or asks any questions
at all and they just get sucked right
into it man as a society is so greedy
we're willing to go to war we're willing
to go places and send these big metal
machines that kill people and
people up just so we can make more money
and the way our society is set up I mean
I've heard it argued and argued
successfully that our society runs on
war you know it runs on the domination
of the other parts of the world and
literally that's the only way you can
control a gigantic chunk of the globe
you have to keep everybody down you know
and that's what our society is based on
we can't be fighting over each other
because you know this guys are like a
million people died in Iraq I never goes
hey long as it doesn't happen over here
but it is that is over here it's just
over here over there it's the same thing
and some people you don't know that were
born somewhere else who got
jacked you get trapped in that whole
idea of you know this is my team these
are my people and you know someone
plays a country music song and
throws up a flag and I man it it
feels good feels good to be in right
feels good god Bless America feels good
singing around with a bunch of other
people and you're all drinking what a
badass on the
planet whoa and that's how people get
recruited
it's a clusterfuck man these poor
kids man she imagine being 18 19
being talked into doing a for a
bunch of bloodthirsty who
just are trying to get whatever they're
trying to get over there whatever the
it is whether it's lithium you know
minerals in the mountains that they used
to make cellphone whether it's ninety
percent plus of the world's opium supply
ninety percent that is a multi
multi-billion dollar business and if you
think these industrialist
that are running the world
are gonna leave that money behind you're
crazy dude they've got United
States Army troops guarding poppy field
there's so much heroin there I
mean it's incredible brother of
the President of Afghanistan his brother
was selling heroin and getting paid by
the CIA I mean god dammit
heroin is absolutely addictive okay
people who try heroin get hooked heroin
is everywhere okay so you need to sell
it someone's selling it who's selling it
I don't know but 90% of it comes from
this one place where we have to be to
save our freedom you you can't criticize
it because if you criticize it you're a
shithead you don't appreciate the troops
and what they're doing for you and
that's not the case at all I just don't
like the idea of these people
leading us in any direction where you
need to sacrifice your life well I don't
believe it I don't believe them and
there's been so many lies I mean
the more you look it up the more they
may go go into any of the stories on the
weapons of mass destruction before we
invaded and compare them to what we
actually know that they really knew when
they said that it's like they did it on
purpose they wanted to get in there for
whatever reason and if it's some
crazy the world is gonna end if we don't
stop this but we can't tell you
like I would love to believe you I would
love to believe that the reason why
you're you're not telling us exactly
what the is going on is because
you're really protecting us from some
insanely evil thing that if we knew
about it it would society would collapse
but our strong brave powerful leaders
are going to guide us without our
knowledge I would love to believe you if
you weren't all full
we're gonna have to step back and
look at it all in a different way and I
don't think you're gonna get that from
just voting for president dealing with
all this nonsense that we have right now
with the with the two-party
system it's we're spinning our wheels
we're not getting any traction it's all
nonsense the same nonsense with Obama
that we dealt with with Bush special
interest groups controlling what people
say and do what direction the country
goes in and save us from the bad guys
shut the up man it's the same
nonsense Operation Northwoods was
something that was plotted out during
the 1960's signed by the Joint Chiefs of
Staff where they were going to fake
terrorist attacks on American civilians
and blame it on the Cuban so we could go
to war with Cuba and involved a bunch of
like blowing up a jetliner they
were gonna have a drone jetliner blow it
up and say that people died on it and
this is gonna get everybody fired up but
going to war with Cuba they were gonna
attack want Onam obey they were gonna
armed cubed friendlies to attack
Guantanamo Bay so that we would have to
go to war with Cuba this is like our own
government they plotted this out this is
like real I remember when I was I
saw JFK the Oliver Stone movie and that
was like part of the premise that JFK
that Oliver Stone was was pushing in his
film is that they killed JFK because
they want to stay in Vietnam they were
making a lot of money in Vietnam and I
remember the time seen that movie going
that is absolutely ridiculous who the
believes that is they gonna start
Wars and keep Wars going just so they
can make money even though it's not a
real war thought of just war nobody
wants to go to war that stupid hippie
well as I got older and I
started investigating history you know
from way back to Vietnam to the Gulf of
Tonkin to all the that happened
when Kennedy and Nixon were in office
all the that happened with Reagan
in the Contras in Nicaragua no sentient
Easterners and all the different various
things that have happened in human
history where it's clear that the United
States is you know we're around
with all kinds of things all the time to
make money
and if there's a bunch of people that
are profiting off a war and then they're
not just popping like a little bit of
money here and there you know you look
at like what so I was like what how much
money Halliburton made for the war we're
talking like billions and billions of
dollars that's like real money
Eisenhower leaving office and he's
giving a speech warning the American
people about the power of the
military-industrial complex you know
when you watch that you're like well
here is a sitting president who's
leaving office and but was the most
important thing that he wants to tell
people is that you have to be careful
because there's a machine here that
wants to go to war there's a business
behind going to other countries and
locking people up and taking their
and they come up with reasons to do this
and they sacrifice American lives to do
this and they do it for profit and it
sounds absolutely ridiculous it sounds
absolutely outrageous that the greatest
country on earth could be involved in
something like that from the get-go but
yet that's what history says that's how
it points it points in that direction it
points in that direction that it's going
in and the council's of government we
must guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence whether sought or
unsought by the military-industrial
complex the potential for the disastrous
rise of misplaced power exists and will
persist we must never let the weight of
this combination endanger our liberties
or democratic processes
tower seven disturbs me the most that
tower seven just went whoosh just like a
controlled demolition
and everybody's like yeah but it had
holes in the building you see the hole
in the building yes I see the hole in
the building but wouldn't it fall
towards that hole why is it falling like
that that doesn't make sense to me with
Tower seven
the way Tower 7 fell it just kinked in
the middle and fell down freefall speed
almost I mean everybody like they'll
nitpick at you always one tenth of a
second slower than freefall even if it
was just close to freefall that's crazy
there was no resistance it just gave up
why we didn't like wiggle and collapse
towards where Jack got jacked it does it
just seems like a controlled demolition
that that bothers me